I think you you can't let that fear win  in those situations Carly Rae Jepsen  refuses to live in fear following it to  devastating tragedies the Orlando  nightclub shooting and the loss of a  voice alum christina Grimmie who was  killed on friday during a fan meet and  greet the call me maybe singer opened up  to ET on Thursday at a Fourier  consideration event in LA for Greece lie  does that deter you at all from wanting  to have fan meet and greets no there's  always going to be some people that you  don't understand the world who can do  horrible things but I think that there  is forevermore good I think I way pride  this weekend was a really heavy one for  us with everything that had happened but  we were determined to go and the mome  that we were there together and singing  as a group and not letting kind of our  fear get in the way it felt like the  strongest healthiest decision we all  could have made and I I think it was a  beautiful night for that reason  you